[Music]
well hey you guys here I am once again
uh remember I said last night on the
live stream that I was going to do
another live stream today uh talking
about this book that I finally finally
finished after all of this time I think
I've been talking about it for months
and months and I finally got around to
finishing it sorry it took me so long if
you were waiting for me to review this
but you know I finally got around to it
so before we get into the book review
let's take a brief moment to mention our
affiliate uh sponsor which in this case
is audible now like I said you prob guys
probably know what audible is it's a
subscription service that lets you
choose from a huge array of audiobooks
and podcasts and things like that that
you can listen to from anywhere you want
uh my own books most of them are
available on Audible as well uh and I
read read them all myself so if you'd
like to read some of my books and don't
really want to like read read them but
actually like listen to me read them to
you then you can go over to Audible and
uh you can have that done for you so
here we go if you click the link in the
description box you will get a free
30-day trial of audible uh which
includes the ability to listen to all of
their like entire catalog which like I
said is books podcast pretty much
anything uh with no credits needed uh
you also get one credit to use on any
selection that you want and you can keep
that forever if you're already an Amazon
Prime member you actually get two
credits uh to purchase whatever you want
and again you can keep that stuff
forever so click the link in the
description box for a free 30-day trial
of audible of course I an audible
affiliate so when you click that link
and sign up I do get a small commission
so just full full disclosure there all
right so now let's talk about this book
I actually have the print one for a
change although I will note I started
reading the print version and I think
what happened is that I don't really in
the house I don't really have our house
is real dark you guys okay so it's like
I don't really have a place where I can
sit in the evening and like read a print
book because it's always like too dark
like even in our bedroom and stuff we
don't have an overhead light we just
have these two little lamps and they're
not bright enough you know my old ass is
so blind that I can't really see anymore
hey
Tammy yeah this is the other new wig
that Tom got me for Christmas it was
this one the one that I wore last night
the the black and the white cuz it's
cool cuz I don't have any like this so
but yeah thank you I really like it too
um but yeah so so I just I think that
was one of the reasons cuz I really
really liked it like I was really into
it but it's just like I never had the
you know the logistics were never right
for me sitting down reading it because
it always too dark and it's just you
know what I mean so then I found out
that um that Kindle unlimited which I
have a subscription to they had put up
the ebook version of it for free so I
could read it for free and I was like
woohoo I can finally finish this book
cuz I can just read it on my computer
you know what I mean which I don't
usually like to do but it's just easier
just the way everything is configured
but I did actually buy this book a long
time ago so I do have the print version
which I'm glad I do because this is
Illustrated and the ebook version like
all the paintings and stuff like that
are black and white and they're still
beautiful but the print version which is
right here actually has um color
paintings in the middle so um cuz you
know
look at oh and also check this out this
is a metal bookmark I got it at books a
million I couldn't resist I mean you
guys are like P horror fans so you know
what that is but if you don't it's the
wallpaper pattern from room 237 in The
Shining so you know cuz I'm a dork like
that um but yeah I had I was like oh my
God I have to it was like $7 but I was
like I don't care I have to get it but
yeah so yeah so if you look in the
middle of the print book trying not to
get a glare on it uh there's these
really gorgeous like paintings of like
all the characters you know and these
are like pretty pretty
freaky uh you know so so I'm kind of I'm
glad that I invested in the print
version but yeah so in case you didn't
see the cover this is called slooh foot
by
Braum um so yeah Gerald Brum is actually
his name but he's obviously uh more
professionally known just by his last
name so he's just this insanely talented
artist and writer I was kind of
peripherally aware of his stuff just
seeing other people talk about it like
when I would be browsing through the
bookstore like sometimes cuz his books
are always so gorgeous like the covers
and stuff that they would always kind of
put them out on display so I always kind
of saw them um he actually started out I
believe as a commercial illustrator like
for big companies like Coca-Cola and
stuff and then later on he went
freelance and started doing art for like
card games and like big car games and I
think he did Magic maybe did some magic
the Gathering I could be wrong about
that but he does like video games book
covers um he does stuff for movies like
I think he did the original like poster
art for Sleepy Hollow the Tim Burton
movie like among other things but that
was the one that I was most familiar
with so obviously Braum is also a
novelist now as far as I'm aware all of
the novels that he's written also
feature like his really beautiful
illustrations in them like this one does
now I get the impression I'm not sure
about sales and everything like that but
just from the chatter about his work I
get the impression that his most popular
work is Krampus the U Lord which came
out in 2012 and I remember seeing that
in the bookstore too but for whatever
reason I just never got around to like
dipping into his written stuff until
just recently when I picked that up um I
actually had seen uh I think it was
Jordine reads which is another YouTube
channel that I watched so she reviews
books and stuff and I think she was
talking about this and I was like oo
that sounds really cool and she really
loved it and I was like I probably
should pick that up so just when I saw
it at the bookstore I was like yeah I
remember Jordine reading at and really
liking it so I thought that I would like
it too so I'm going to say if you're
into historical horror or folk horror
and especially if you liked the Robert
agar movie The Witch you will probably
love this this will be right in your
wheelhouse um and I would definitely
recommend it if you're into any of that
kind of stuff uh it's very
immersive it's just like this harrowing
story where
things go from bad to worse to like
[__] terrible you know what I mean
and it's just the whole time you're like
oh no oh no it's just it's one of those
kind of stories um has a great great
great lead character and kind of like a
really cool narrative that you know
delves into witchcraft you know
religious
intolerance um maybe even like the
nature of humans relationships with
their gods you know I mean like
different types of gods which I thought
was really cool so the story is set in a
Puritan Village called Sutton in 1666 I
think it's either in Connecticut or West
Virginia I can't
remember and the protagonist is a young
woman I believe she's 19 or 20 or
something like that named Abitha
Williams now she's originally English
she's from London but she was
essentially like sold off by her dad as
a wife to a Puritan in the new world and
she had never met the person before
obviously they just stuck her on a ship
and was like hey you going to go marry
this guy bye you know what I mean that
kind of [__] um now luckily for her at
least at first her husband the guy she's
married to Edward is a nice man like
he's very kind he's very gentle uh he is
quite a bit older than she is um and
he's really reserved and really
introverted so their relationship like
they do have sex and stuff but he seems
kind of awkward and um you know and so
he doesn't have like a lot of passion
and stuff because you know he's a puran
they're a little uptight and [__] like
that so so it's kind of more like a
friendship or a partnership but he does
like feel um you know sexual attraction
for her and stuff like that and she kind
of feels it for him too but it's kind of
like it's kind of a cool relationship
that they have actually so the two of
them live on this Farm which is kind of
out in the Wilds like outside of town
like some distance and so they work
together like I said they're good
partners to kind try and like make this
Farm profitable like make it work right
now Abitha because she's kind of from
the big City she's very um strong willed
she's very independent she's real mouthy
um so she's having a really hard time um
adjusting to this Puritan [__] you
know what I mean um she's actually been
reprimanded several times uh and
threatened to like be put in the stocks
and whatnot which you know they have a
lot of stocks in this town because like
seriously you fart wrong and they're
going to put you in the stocks cuz
they're like Heathen you know you know
what I mean it's that it's that bad um
so she does though seem to be genuinely
trying to fit in like for the sake of
her husband you know what I mean but she
kind of like like I said she's kind of
mouthy so she she kind of like can't
really keep her opinions to herself you
know what I mean like when something
pisses her off she's going to say
something she's like [__] I shouldn't
have said anything you know what I mean
it was that kind of thing um so
obviously this has put her at odds with
most of the other towns folk they still
see her as an outs Ider a troublemaker
you know what I mean they don't really
they they aren't really add that into
her you know what I mean so there's also
this very big sticky problem that
emerges near the beginning of the
story um and this problem is in the form
of Edward's horrible older brother
Wallace
Williams so when Edward and Wallace's
dad died he left two farms in Sutton
both of them are in Wallace's name
because he's the eldest brother
so Edward the younger brother was given
kind of the shitty smaller one to live
on while Wallace got the big nice one
you know what I mean now Edward and
Abitha have been paying essentially rent
like part of their uh crop or whatever
to Wallace like once a month or once a
season or however um and they actually
only have one more payment to him and
then they'll own the little farm like
free and
clear however without telling them or
anyone really
Wallace put up the farm that Edward is
living on as collateral for like a
tobacco growing business venture that he
was starting well that business venture
didn't work out he lost his shirt and
now his creditors are obviously asking
for
payback so Wallace this douchy
condescending [__] shows up at
Edward's farm and basically tells his
brother um hey you and your wife now owe
half of your yield every season to
Wallace's creditor who's this guy named
Lord Mansfield for the next 20 years so
obviously they only had one more payment
before they owned the farm outright and
now that has just been you know pissed
down Wallace's leg pretty much now
they're stuck in
indenture essentially like you know
tenant Farmers for like 20 years to come
right because of Wallace doing this
underhanded [__] obviously Abitha is
[__] furious about this as you know
understandably as you should be but you
know this was 1666 this is a Puritan
Village uh women were just supposed to
like sit down and shut up and not give
their opinions about anything especially
business because that was man stuff so
frustratingly Edward is actually kind of
passive because he's sort of used to his
older brother who's kind of a bully like
kind of always kicking him around you
know what I mean and so he never really
stands up for
himself now later on Abitha who
absolutely will stand up for herself and
him she convinces Edward to grow a pair
and go to the town magistrate to see
what can be done about this because it
seems like you know an injustice you
know what I mean now this does initially
work out in their favor the magistrates
do agree that it was a dick move for
Wallace to put Edward's Farm up against
the loan instead of his own Farm you
know what I mean CU they're like well
why didn't you he's like well I own them
both so it shouldn't matter blah blah
blah but they you know kind of sort
through it and the m are like yeah you
guys are kind of right like you need to
work out some other deal Wallace so
Wallace obviously is [__] livid about
this and accuses Abitha of essentially
poisoning Edward against him and so he
says well I'm just going to go like over
you guys' heads over the magistrates
heads rather and he's going to go to the
higher-ups in Hartford um who he's
pretty tight with uh unfortunately cuz
all the [__] hang out together I
guess so Edward and Abitha you know
seemingly they can keep the the farm for
now although it's still like on pretty
Shaky Ground but then and this isn't
really well you know all my book reviews
I do kind of go into could you do like
the first third of the story or
something and I try not to like spoil
the ending but I know that some people
like to go into books not knowing
anything about them which if you do I
don't know why you would be watching a
book review about it but you know what
I'm saying I'm just saying that this
isn't really a spoiler because it
happens very early in the story and I
think it's even in the description of
the book but you know if you don't want
to know anything about the story then
you might want to go read the book and
then come back later you know what I
mean I'm just saying so uh so yeah so
maybe they can keep the farm sort of
provisionally but then a horrible
horrible tragedy takes place that ends
up kind of throwing everything into
chaos so one of the couples goats whose
name is Samson like wanders off and it
seems that he falls into this really
deep dark creepy hole that maybe is
haunted like it kind of has like some
whispery voices and [__] like that
coming out of it
now Edward tries to go and retrieve the
animal because it's very valuable
obviously because you can get milk from
it and you know and meat and stuff but
Edward falls into the same pit and dies
and this leaves Abitha obviously a very
vulnerable Widow in a town full of
people who don't particularly like her
now Wallace naturally like a vulture
swoops in immediately like following W's
death like I was like the same day or
the next day he's just like oo you know
what I mean rubbing his hands together
so he's trying to get his grubby mitts
on the farm right which is what he
wanted all along so he can use it to pay
off his debt he also offers he's like
you know I this is like what happened to
you and it's like I'm willing to be
magnanimous he's that kind of
[__] and he's like I will even
marry you off marry Abitha off to his
son Wallace's son Isaac and it's like
and you can come live in our household
as a servant until you've paid all the
debt off you know what I mean obviously
she's not a big fan of this plan because
[__] that so she's very resourceful
though and like I said she's not afraid
of like standing up for herself so she
goes to the magistrates and says hey you
know Edward was my husband I'm his widow
legally I should be able to allow you
know be allowed to like run the farm on
my own cuz I'm technically his
representative right and if he was alive
he would be running it he's not alive so
I should be able to run it now the
magistrates provisionally they're like
yeah I guess you have a good point there
so they provisionally give her
permission to do this but absolutely
nobody thinks that she's going to be
able to bring in the entire Harvest by
herself because one nobody in the town
likes her and two she doesn't have the
money to hire anybody so she's kind of
on her own you know what I mean and so
Wallace figures he's kind of pissed off
about this but he's like H it's you know
it's only a matter of time before the
farm is mine anyway because there's
absolutely no way that she's going to be
able to bring in that entire Harvest
like on her own you know what I mean now
for a while it would seem that his uh
prediction is correct Abitha is having a
hell of a [__] time working the farm
alone as you know it's a big job you
know what I mean and she's just this
little 19-year-old girl or whatever and
to make matters worse the weather is not
cooperating either like there's a
significant lack of rain I don't even
know if it's like drought but it's kind
of like a drought like over the summer
so her corn won't grow
now she's very very stubborn and she
just absolutely does not want to give in
to Wallace at all because she can't
stand his smug [__] face so she
will just she just works herself to the
point of exhaustion and
starvation but you know she gets to a
point where there's just like all this
[__] happens and it's just getting worse
and worse and she's like you know what I
might as well just give up and hand the
farm over to Wallace and she even kind
of considers like kind of like just
doing away with herself like you know I
could just jump down in this well and
all my problems will be over you know
what I mean so it's that kind of [__]
when she's at her lowest point though
she seemingly gets something of a
Lifeline now up until this stage in the
story there have been like short
sections of the book written from the
point of view of some kind of creature
called father who doesn't seem to
remember like who or what he
is father is accompanied by three little
creatures
who call themselves The Wild folk and
they're trying to get him to revert to
his true nature which is kind of
bloodthirsty and feed this sapling in
the forest that they call paa with human
blood so it will regrow cuz apparently
it used to be there and it was this big
like magical tree or whatever but now
it's gone and it's they're trying to
regrow it but that's the only way you
can feed it with human blood now these
three creatures I showed kind of the
paintings of them are named Forest Creek
and sky and they are an opossum a fish
that swims through the air as though it
was water and a raven um and all of them
have the faces of kind of evil looking
human children like with little sharp
teeth and stuff and some of them also
have like other human limbs like human
hands and stuff cuz I think the Raven
actually has human hands like instead of
Claws and also human face so kind of
freaky you know what I mean now it turns
out that these wild Folk actually fed
the missing goat Samson and Edward ab's
husband to Father like in the process of
trying to wake him up and get him to
remember who he is now Abitha it should
be noted is the daughter of a cunning
woman um you know like a witch kind of
um so when she was growing up before she
you know when she still lived in England
her mom had taught her like various
charms and spells when she was a kid
like her mom died when she was young so
Abitha sometimes times like makes little
little love potions and remedies and
stuff like that for the women in Sutton
in town um this is all kept on the
download though cuz I mean the the
charms are like grudgingly tolerated but
they're not really approved of you know
what I mean it's kind of so it's kind of
like a gray
area so just when Abitha is at the point
of just giving up everything she happens
to meet father this creature who is
actually fascinated with her because he
seems to like sense her magic and he
believes that she can help him discover
his identity and like what his purpose
is now Forest Creek and sky are pretty
adamant that father should kill her
because humans are never to be trusted
and they'll destroy the forest and
they'll destroy the rest of the wild
folk if they're allowed to but father is
kind of really tormented by his lack of
memory and his lack of knowing who he is
to really listen to them and so he
actually ends up establishing sort of an
uneasy partnership I guess with Abitha
kind of helping her Channel her unused
magic in ways that will help her
Farm in return for her help in like
sorting out his nature because he's not
entirely sure if his nature is as a
Creator or a destroyer you know what I
mean so as you can imagine AB
befriending a horned goat-legged uh
Forest spirit that absolutely kills
people and feeds on their
blood is not going to sit too well with
the little Puritans there and sudden you
know what I mean and a lot of very very
very bad [__] happens before you know
the whole thing is over and that's about
all I want to spoil about it because it
goes balls to the wall like toward the
end
so yeah this was a great book I really
liked this a lot um just the way it's
written it really kind of like immerses
you in this world which is just kind of
like simultaneously like really really
brutal and also like really kind of
magical so I was really into the
mythology surrounding father and his
ambiguous stance as to whether he was
like a noble protector God or a
merciless Slayer God I mean that was
like really well done and it kind of
introduced the idea of kind of kind of
more pagan gods which were more nuanced
um in the sense that they better reflect
the uncertainties and of nature you know
what I mean so he was that kind of a God
I also really really liked the
development of abitha's Friendship with
him and her constant like push and pull
cuz she was just you know forever in
turmoil about whether she really was
consort in with the devil because she
didn't know she just met him and he's
has very devilish aspects but on the
other hand he kind of seems like an okay
dude too so she's not really like sure
what to think and the more they do stuff
and magic and stuff together and the
more she develops like her magical like
her witch powers she's just sitting
there am I like cuz she still believes
in God and she's still a Christian and
stuff like that so she's sitting there
going like am I damning My Immortal Soul
by like hanging out this dude even
though he seems like he's okay you know
he's not a dude he's a creature you know
what I mean like a god um also going to
say the largely horrid people of Sutton
there were a couple of them that were
okay but most of them were just terrible
[__] um but they were like really
good antagonists and they kind of
demonstrated you know what religion can
do to people's Common Sense uh you know
if taken to extremes CU like I said
there was kind of like a witch trial
aspect to this as well and you can see
how the kind of [__] happened in Salem
similar kind of thing um and Wallace in
particular was intensely hatable so part
of the fun of the book was kind of
waiting for him to get his richly
deserved come upins because you knew it
was going to happen like you knew it was
building up to it um and you were just
like oh my God I can't wait till this
guy gets his [__] [__] pushed in you
know what I mean because he was such a
dick um now I'm going to say like I felt
like maybe I saw other people complain
about this I didn't really think this
but some people said oh the buildup of
the story was really slow
um but like I said I don't really mind
that at all cuz you just kind of got
into the rhythm of it you know what I
mean um and I was really invested in
abius character so it's like I kept
getting outraged on her behalf like
every time some new indignity like
befell her you know what I mean cuz
every time this just gets worse and
worse and it's just like the universe is
just like [__] on this poor girl you
know what I mean and you're just like oh
my God something good has to happen
because it just gets worse and worse I
mean the thing about like living in this
time period perod as a woman uh you know
in this time period in this environment
would have been an absolute [__]
nightmare um and I think this book does
a really good job of
conveying just how hopeless somebody in
abitha's position would have how how
hopeless that would have been you know
what I mean and it really makes you
understand how maybe somebody that was
in that position
would want to or get to a point where
they needed to join forces with a could
be a demon not really sure um if it
meant that she could just get like the
tiniest sliver of of an advantage like
over all of these people that were like
[__] with her you know what I mean so
you could totally see how that would
happen hey Marcus I've always wanted to
read this one yeah it's great I really
really like
it um now keep in mind that I mean the
first two-thirds of it like I said is
this kind of build up and just the life
[__] on her and then you know when
she meets father and then that all that
magical stuff starts to happen but the
final third of the book is pretty
violent and Bleak um you know there's
women being tortured people having their
guts ripped out um one scene of Cat
death which was [__] horrible and
it's just like I cuz the whole time like
when I knew cuz I knew she had a cat and
of course she's going to get like
accused of that being her familiar and
stuff like that and I was like oh man I
was the whole time I was like this is
not going to end well for this cat and
wa it really didn't and I was just kind
of like oh man that that like almost
made me cry I like reading that stuff
about the cat I'm like that is so [__]
up it was like so [__] up so just know
that going in it's not the most graphic
thing ever don't get me wrong it's not
like extreme horror or anything but it
does get a little bit gnarly toward the
end so just kind of a heads up like I
said there is like torture and stuff
like that so I'm going to say like
anybody that has any interest at all in
you know the history of witch trials or
um you know ancient folklore ancient
American folklore Native American
folklore or something like this um I
feel you should probably love this uh
and like I said if you really liked
Robert Edgar's the witch um you'll
probably be really into this too so I
would absolutely recommend it to anybody
that liked that kind of stuff like
without hesitation um and I'm going to
say like I showed you some of the
paintings that were in there they're
also just there's more of them than that
but they're like really really stunning
that's why it's kind of cool to get the
print book because they have the color
ones and there the ebook is just they're
just black and white but they still look
great you know what I mean um and I was
and I like that he had each character
like a painting of them you know what I
mean cuz it made me like helped me
picture the story a lot more vividly
like seeing what the characters look
like so this is my first work of his
that I've read of Brahms and um I'm
definitely going to be reading more of
it cuz I'm you know I'm just vibing I'm
vibing with it and I'm just surprised
that it took me this long to get to it
but you know better late than never I
guess uh but yeah I really really like
this a lot and I would definitely
recommend it if you're into that kind of
stuff so I guess I'm going to wrap it up
for the day uh remember to come back
tomorrow night for our sidetracks show
at 7:30 p.m. Eastern Standard time so me
and Tom will just be here drinking and
shooting the [__] and um I might do
another live stream probably a movie but
I'm not sure what movie it's going to be
at it might be Sunday or Tuesday I'm not
really entirely sure but uh but yeah so
thanks for dropping by and listening to
my book review today and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow night good night